[Applause]
you know uh that must i mean
it's still relatively early in your
career i'm guessing and uh
you're working with robert de niro yeah
that was uh how do you top that that
must have been really fun i don't think
you do i think i've reached the zenith
of my career probably maybe not probably
because now you're here
with the maestro exactly though
uh no it was amazing uh to work with him
i uh
you know we rehearsed that whole piece
which i had written
for him and the whole time i couldn't
think of anything to say to him it takes
like an hour to rehearse a piece
and uh i just couldn't come up with any
words like what do you say to robert de
niro like are you having a good time
right uh and so for like a whole hour
and talk to him and then like
two hours later we ended up on an
elevator together and it was like
awkward
just the two of you there's the two of
us and uh finally he looks over and he
goes uh
did you write that piece i was like yeah
yeah i did he goes
it's funny funny
and i was like that's it that's the best
moment of my life that's gonna be it
right there i probably should i
shouldn't even have kids would have been
funny if you disagree with them no it's
not
yeah yeah yes it is no no it's not bad
do you hang out with uh any of the
guests uh yeah we uh
we have some eyes you know at the
parties it's fun that's one of the nice
things about the show is we get the
parties afterwards and uh you got yeah
i used to work there and there's a party
after every show after everything we
thought about doing that here but we do
a show every night and we thought it
would be really funny every night we had
a big party afterwards like
but no so once a week is more than
enough but uh we had fish a couple weeks
ago and they were really
great guys it sounds like you had
ordered it at the restaurant yeah yeah
we had fish at the party it was
wonderful
uh but though they were they were great
guys and i was talking to him but
something really
unique was happening which was every
like two minutes like a 19 year old dude
in like a ski cap
and like a backpack with patches sewn on
would like sort of walk up and just
start nodding his head
and like listening and then he go uh hey
uh hey dudes you uh
you want to get hot and uh the lee sugar
fish was like no no we're cool thanks
man he'd be like all right
you know where to find me and then he'd
leave and literally a minute later
another guy another 19 year old dude
who'd just be there it was like a
receiving line in a wedding of guys
who just wanted to just have yeah yeah
that's nice so
yeah it's always nice at a party you um
we we had hugh grant here just a couple
of nights ago and i was thinking about
the time
you look a lot i mean it's not just me
but look you have a hugh grant
look to your face yeah it's true we have
the same face so for for years i've been
getting by
uh at cocktail parties with just being
like uh no i mean the who the whole
thing is
rightfully yeah and it's really
like
[Laughter]
the ladies love it yeah the key is you
just say dreadful
frightful and quiet pretty much just
revolve those
yeah but he stopped stammering because i
saw him on your show the other night
he's really like well put together now
like
has a whole act together and it's really
hurting my game
you can't do his thing anymore because
he pulled it together and started making
sentences i thought we were a team who
grant that
um you're getting a lot of air time
you you know this is your second season
yep and you're on that show a lot which
is a
sign that it's going well the first
season though yeah a little tougher
because i remember they would announce
you at the beginning and i'd be looking
for you i'd be like oh this new guy here
he's funny and some of the people here
on staff know him and say oh he's a
really funny performer so i'll be
looking for you on starting out live
just to see let's see what this kid has
yeah but i wouldn't see you until maybe
90 minutes at the end i did that
you'd be waving at the end i love it
sometimes a cast member who never gets
on but at the end
they're waving and hugging everybody
yeah sometimes you do that with a host
who
like really doesn't know who you are
after a week you haven't done anything
with them and they're really like you
you see in their eyes they're like why
is the janitor on stage
it doesn't help that you're always
holding a broom yeah well it's like my
lust
or whatever it is squidger what i came
from what she called it now uh
so uh but the first season
i'd always be looking for you and i
wouldn't see you and then people were
saying like no he was the one in the
bear costume
yeah and you were always in a bear
costume on that show
yeah explain that well there's not a lot
of glamour in the first year and a
writer asked me if i wouldn't mind
playing a bear
in one of these scenes and uh the scene
kept almost making it on the show
and it was it involved a bear kissing
like a you know beautiful hollywood
starlet so it actually worked out really
well for me because it would get cut
and then i'd sort of hope every time
starlet came back like i hope we do that
bear thing again
right but you're wearing like a giant
bear head so you're a full
foot away from like gwyneth paltrow's
mouth because the snout is that
long um but the bear is not hers right
exactly
but uh she's got a huge honker folks
it doesn't show up on camera
uh but it's amazing because if i think i
know what it would be like if a bear ate
me whole and then that bear made out
with gwyneth paltrow
i know exactly what that because you're
in there and you see her that's gotta be
so surreal the awful part is i think i
recall now that like i would actually in
this bear suit i think i opened my mouth
like during the kissing scenes
giant there so you're alone in this
giant like like giant
you know bear head a full foot away from
her and you're oh that's so sad
yeah it's method it's called method it's
called method i'm sorry but uh
we um we have a montage here a tribute
to all the times you were in this bear
costume and it actually i don't think
got on the air
with these different starlets but
luckily they roll videotape
uh at the dress show just beforehand so
we have a little montage here enjoy
[Music]
that's the same costume
that's the same costume we use for the
masturbating bearing bear yeah
yeah that'll surprise you that's really
weird i don't like seeing him do that
those other roles yeah that angers me
why can't we afford our own bear costume
that bothers me that we have one bear
costume and start out live uses it well
every time i would like walk down the
hallway and it was like just heads
turning people be like it's a
masturbating bear
right right i signed a lot of autographs
are you masturbating beer yes i am uh
i heard and this is just this is small
talk but i like to end my interviews
with small talk
small chat i heard a rumor that you're
going to be signing up to come to my gym
the gym
that's true i i i basically got this
invitation to come check out this this
gym
and as i mentioned it's right here it's
like across the skating r sports club
and it's right here and it's perfect for
us
but i'm uh as i'm checking it out
they're they're sort of showing me all
the
workout equipment and they go you know
who works out here is conan o'brien
sort of so they're like selling the gym
based on your physique that's like the
worst idea i've ever heard of
yeah that's the thing you know who works
here works out here who's that don
knotts yeah
mr furley works out here
that's not a good i'm not a good
advertisement for jim i mean wesley
why did you agree with that right away
well i i decided maybe you've got the
maybe you have the perfect i said i'm
not a good advertisement for a gym
anyone i know
no you're not and i just thought you
were gonna go the old no no you're all
man yeah i tried i didn't it didn't feel
right
i'm putting you back into a bear costume
immediately uh staring out live with
host uh robert de niro and musical guest
nora jones yep
that's the one that's on uh what this
weekend today must be
they're rerunning it that fast they just
get
okay i'm going to get a call now man it
seems like they're repeating that
awfully quickly
seth meyers thank you very much for
being here good to have you here we'll
be right back
jimmy carr